hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and there is
a lot to discuss as we storm the palace
open the gates let's get into episode
112
of hunter hunter one one two eleven two
eleven two
two numbers there were a lot of styles
used in episode 112 as the human storm
the ant nest as it were and the title of
the episode was quite indicative of how
the narrator is telling the story as
well as how we're supposed to read the
situation
straight through the arc we've been
thrown back and forth between who are
the protagonists and who are the
antagonists and all i know after
watching that episode is that i still
actually don't know who is an antagonist
and who's a protagonist
it's a fascinating position to be in and
absolutely is encouraged by the narrator
describing both sides of the combat as
though he's on their side
when talking about pito falling it's
deemed to be a good thing because pito
can see what's happening in the palace
and react accordingly in a way that's
good for the ants
meanwhile shoot's revelation of a broken
cage is good because we're shown
how much of a role model gon was for him
that almost duplicity
of narration means that we're almost
squarely in the middle
and we can understand why natera just
stands there watching while mary deals
with komugi which
is really what this whole episode was
building toward right i mean
the whole kamugi arc really all the
pointing out of how weak and useless she
is all the noting of how much of a waste
of time and energy and
yet he's still fallen in love with her
and needs her healed and now we know of
course what's going to happen right
unless pito's actively trying to bring
her back to exactly what she was at
before kamuki will no longer be blind or
sniffly or any number of things right
we don't know what it'll do to her mind
but she's not going to have the barriers
she had before
she'll be at full strength for a kid she
might have nen
if her health were a limiting factor
before she'll actually get to see
mary on marilyn and the king and that's
exciting
if we get to there at the moment we're
moving almost second by second
and part of what i'm loving about this
sequence is that expansion and
contraction of time
we've got our little monster gone who is
only looking for one thing
pito and once he gets to them what's he
going to do because
if he gets to them before pito's
finished healing then what will he have
as much honor as naterro i mean we have
hunter hunter as the title of the show
and monster monster as the episode title
who is the monster who is the hunter and
who is human
kilowatt knowing his grandfather is in
the building may or may not come into
play too i guess
it sort of suggests that they'll see
each other at some point or that one or
the other will be able to take
news of what happens back to their
families but i'm really not
sure overall in terms of sound design
the episode felt like it started very
broad and chipped away until we were in
total silence with mary and kamugi
the fact that pito was warned by the
aura of the king as they got closer says
a whole lot about how
undefined that concern is that it was
the same energy being given out to
everyone
indiscriminately shows that the king was
wasn't even angry so much as grieving
and for everyone in that room to note
the tenderness and humanity with which
he held her the moment the art softened
around pito and became romantic we get a
glimpse into exactly who kamuki is to
marry
pito doesn't get confused or worried or
afraid or concerned pito gets to work
because it's likely the queen they
failed to protect and now they must do
their best work to bring them back
potentially sacrificing the king to do
so
more specifically doing as the king says
not as
their instincts say the tears that come
feel like a response to
all of that the fear of knowing they can
no longer help the king physically and
knowing that the other two may not find
him in time to lay themselves down in
service of him the personal failure
involved in needing to heal
if they'd done their job in the first
place they wouldn't have needed to right
so much is communicated just in the few
frames of conversation and tears and the
narration that
his face the king's face returned to
normal if someone's face is back to
normal in the in
the face of such intense emotion in in
in spite of such intense emotion we know
that's a bad thing right like we all
know that
as it is anytime he's had a human
emotion we haven't seen it it's been
hidden
every time if we can't see his face it's
almost like a greek chorus
in ancient greek theater they never
performed the most intense scenes
instead they described them for the
audience because anything you can
imagine
will be more intense than what can be
shown that's sort of what's happening
here and
it totally works we put emotion on that
blanked out black and white frame
in silence we see that grief play out
and the highlighting of that one streak
of blood before we get further in
it's all crucial working backwards in
the episode everyone but gone had a
freeze moment despite the minutiae of
what's happening in combat what i loved
about this episode is
that we saw each and every character
freeze for a reason or need to take a
moment to re-engage with their purpose
the fact that so many phrases were
detailed was a source of real joy as a
psychologist because
it showed how everyone's trauma and
emotions were activated differently
natero who treats human-like behaviors
humanely while kilwa's grandfather looks
on
passively and confused even as the king
just walks past them
shoot whose cage ability so clearly is
used to capture others and make them
small is obviously a metaphor
for the cage he felt he was in a cage
that is now
open we had killa all knowing kilwa who
expects
everything but knows how to deal with
nothing until others act
yupi who can only act and nothing more
because he's made of
checks notes magical beasts aha
knuckle who has no idea how long it'll
take for his power to pull up down
and gone the greatest monster who thinks
of nothing but his goal
more than up i would say he is the true
monster yupi has no self-preservation
not as gone but not being human we might
assume that up
also has no capacity for empathy as a
human gone has capacity but he's a
sociopath
so can it be engaged and if it can will
he allow it to be
we come back again to that question
early on in the series that i keep
coming back to and i'm so sorry but i'm
also not at all sorry
if you have to choose between who lives
and who dies who do you choose
is kamoogie a possible casualty of that
decision-making process that's been
going on for
i don't know at least a year for me
let's take a look at episode 113
and find out 113 and the eloquence of
morels
notwithstanding this episode was hugely
emotional for everyone involved and i'm
beginning to wonder whether the fact
that they're all running on emotion is
going to be a help or a hindrance
in the case of gone who almost shuts
down due to his emotion and looks like
the creepiest kid on the planet while
watching a couple of grown-ups walk off
with a giant bug
i don't really know what's going to
happen next and
i like that i really like that i have
the sense that he
and perth will be of a chord though if
perth makes it to pito i suspect that
puff will try to kill komugi himself
despite his claims that he's a traitor
and sick of the king's care for a lowly
human
shia is going through a lot and it seems
the most important thing for him
is that he go through it in the most
melodramatic way possible
actively deciding to go where the king
was not because he couldn't bear to see
the king with someone he's decided to
spend time with sounds like pure
jealousy
and not only pure jealousy but some
extreme supremacism on his part given he
also has human dna to him which he seems
to have forgotten
it's interesting to look at things in
that context since i'm
who i am i guess in so many ways but the
idea that violin butterfree could
abandon the king because the king isn't
living up to his fanatical ideals
shows us just how quickly fanatical
ideals can get out of hand
i wonder whether he even knew what those
ideals were before kamugi came along and
what he would deem to be appropriate
ideals given the life cycle of a chimera
ant
should also be hardwired and eventually
the king would have had to take a queen
to continue the breeding line nope what
would he have accepted would anything
have been
acceptable a number of ants have
defected at this point for a variety of
reasons and i find it fascinating that
this has occurred so close to the king
and how the god have all reacted
differently pito sees what the king
wants
and does it because that to them is
loyalty yupi lays down his life
immediately to make sure no one can get
to the king because that to him
is loyalty shia laperfe does not go to
the king deliberately
because that is loyalty it's just about
what he's being loyal to
right allowing the king to go
unprotected shows that he's happy for
the king to be
killed for his choices essentially and
the fact that he was still there even
after all that happened and wasn't
rushing and returning to tarot and gone
for a moment natera was telling gon
where pito was but nothing more does
naterroth know how much of a monster
gone
is with the shadowy behaviour there
surely is humanity only for people like
natero or would he be disappointed in
gon's behavior if gone kills pito before
komugi's healed and how much does it
take to heal a technically
unremarkable human shoot has reached his
final form
he's going to rescue everyone on his
hand copter something i love about shoot
is that he's sort of fueled by his
cowardice so making things worse for
himself raises that cowardice index
which
makes it sound like i have a full coward
scale and now i've decided i must
excuse me while i get on that number one
are you such a coward that a small boy
is your inspiration
check two are you such a coward that not
being able to see your opponent makes
you
cooler check are you flying on your own
flying hand
check conclusion you may be shoot scared
but you get the job done
well done speaking of getting the job
done kiladon gone
and beeped things up for everyone hey
but all in the name of friendship it's
kind of hard to tell whether killer goes
in to protect icalgo and doesn't know
why because he's never really needed to
with gone other than to take him out of
a fight or if he goes in to protect
octobuddy because he actually cares
about him in a way that's genuinely
wholesome
gone has never to my recollection
actually thanked kilwa for what he does
he just takes it as given that kilwa
will do what's needed and ask keowa to
do stuff for him
or says i'm sorry i'm gonna be
you know unable to help you in this
situation because i'm gone
and selfish ikalgo might be the first
time kilwa's experienced genuine
gratitude from someone and that's
remarkable to a great degree ikalgo is
the friend kilwa should have had
gone is what he got with hikalgo kilwa
feels like a part of his life he feels
intrinsically connected to octobuddy's
survival with gon he spends so much time
observing that it's hard to tell if
they're friends or if gon
just likes having a hype crew around the
nature of friendship in general became a
huge point of this episode really with
shoot helping morel who helped knuckle
and after pito did what the king asked
while sheila perf left him to fend for
himself and how natero knows gone has a
score to settle with pito so helps on
that account there's a lot of different
relationships all on display here and
the vast number of art mediums
used to show movement or softness or
clarity with keewa
we went from the harsh outline sketch of
a new creation to the romantic soft
charcoals of a character going to help
his friend and
kill our sequences and i know i'm
jumping around but the episode had me
mentally doing that too
we're seeing moment by moment how these
characters are reacting to their
situations
and gon didn't even notice kilwa wasn't
there because why would he sociopath has
a task to do
and if kilwa is dead we can deal with
that later right he was confused
because it wasn't the plan and then keel
was confused because his emotions got in
the way of the task
kilwa's white light art in essence has
proven that kiwa
is human the humanity is there meanwhile
gone is dark and empty and we know that
there is nothing there but a monster
for now at least and you know what on
that sober note that's it from me
if you enjoyed this mentally bouncing
review click here
here maybe here make sure you're getting
enough food and water and sleep and have
a burger and all that good stuff and
i'll see you
next time